I only cook with non toxic cast iron or stainless steel.
And cast iron doesn't have to be expensive,
there's some really cheap versions out there.
This one is a little bit nicer.
It has a machine polished surface
so it's got a super smooth cooking surface,
kinda like how the vintage ones used to be.
Now before you go putting food in any cast iron,
you wanna make sure it's oiled up and at a nice hot temperature
so food doesn't stick. Cooking with cast iron is super easy.
There's just a few little rules you need to follow with cook
while cooking and cleaning.
This was the very first time I used this cast iron pan
and even with the factory seasoning it was ready to cook.
Grab yourself some cast iron pans and get cooking!